[Music]
let's talk about underworld this is your
third time playing Selene and first of
all a very great action in in these
movies and look at these films and I
think you must know now how to really
kick some ass you must it looks like
you've learned how to do it it does look
like that I mean you know I feel like I
can I'm always sort of mapping out my
exit strategy what I'm gonna use as a
weapon that could go in your gullet you
know do you mean better
no-one's threatened recently if you
walked into this friendly environment
this talk show we've been invited you
actually thought if trouble broke out
this could go into Conan's throat how do
you take Andy out yeah you know you've
used this on me how does Andy go I know
I'd be on the floor crying you it's
interesting because in the movies you're
required to drive and be an expert
driver in the movies but you don't drive
in real life I don't not so much yeah
but I'm curious is it difficult to
pretend you drive even even though
you're a very good actress is it hard to
pretend you drive when you don't drive
well yeah and the thing is I don't
normally use a machine gun either and
for some reason I do trouble with that
it's easier to fake the machine gun
what's hard about faking driving it's
such a fruit I think because also you're
usually driving along and having an
intense conversation with somebody and I
always have to be told no Kate you have
to look at education because I forget
you know you're supposed to get where
you're going in a giant yes that and
wing mirrors and clicky things and I
mean not that my character indicate what
you think what kind of car are you
driving anything but yeah so that I can
feel a bit silly in that and we it was
harder this time because we had we had
two very lovely Swedish directors and
all the all the car stuff was a green
screen with them on the loudhailer with
quite a thick accent and also me being
completely stupid about driving so they
were yelling directions to you while you
were trying to pretend that you knew how
to drive you have two Swedish men
yelling at you yeah I'm sort of
pretending I pretend the monster is
coming and things like that do you know
cuz we see there wasn't a real Ian Stern
now one point they shouted lift up your
chin lift up your [ __ ] so I'm sort of
sitting there kind of like what's that
for and they make
I saw that scene where you're driving
like this either it's a terrific scene
we have a clip here in action scene from
the film anything we need to know for
this I believe this is you using
explosives I think I might be blowing up
an elevator shaft
blowing up notes something you do in
real life let's take a look this clip
from Underworld Awakening I'm ready
[Music]
[Music]
that's your cue
[Applause]